en ocasiones una estructura de puntos no
es suficiente para completar la
descripción de una molécula o de unión a
veces necesitamos dos o más y aquí este
es un ejemplo este es el unión acetato y
este su estructura de puntos y no
describe completamente al aceptar a la
unión acetato necesitamos dibujar otra
estructura resonante muy bien y para
hacer eso vamos a tomar un par de estos
electrones que están digamos solitarios
en esta molécula ok y vamos a formar un
doble enlace estos dos electrones van a
poder formar un doble enlace con este
carbono que tenemos aquí y al mismo
tiempo vamos a tomar estos dos
electrones que forman parte de este
enlace de estos dos electrones pi y los
vamos a mover para formar para pasar a
ser electrones
digamos solitarios que estén en este
oxígeno
así que vamos a dibujar estas
estructuras resonantes y vamos a tener
que utilizar estos corchetes cuando
queramos trabajar con estructuras
resonantes y además hay que poner
nuestra nuestra flecha doblé digamos que
íbamos a poner esta flecha doble y ahora
sí podríamos dibujar nuestra estructura
que nos queda muy bien entonces la
estructura que nos queda es la siguiente
vamos a tener
este carbono conectado con este oxígeno
verdad solo que ahora tenemos otro
enlace tenemos otro enlace con este
carbono éste sigue conectándose con este
otro carbono y ahora lo que teníamos
como un doble enlace pasa a ser un
enlace simple verdad con este oxígeno
nada más que ahora tiene 6 electrones
solitarios alrededor
y de hecho hay que cerrar nuestro
corchete verdad déjenme hacerlo un
poquito mejor ahí tenemos nuestro
corchete así que aquí tenemos dos
estructuras resonantes para el unión
aceptado y ninguna de estas estructuras
describe completamente de la unión
acetato verdad necesitamos dibujar un
híbrido de estos dos y antes de hacer
eso vamos a dejar bien claro que fue lo
que ocurrió
estos dos electrones que teníamos en el
oxígeno pasaron a hacer este enlace
verdad ahora ya forman parte como de ese
enlace por otro lado este enlace que
estoy pintando en azul verdad de estos
dos electrones que pasaron a ser digamos
estos dos electrones que se encuentran
al lado del oxígeno muy bien
así que si queremos pensar en un híbrido
de estos dos podríamos digamos dibujar
algo por el estilo no podríamos dibujar
un enlace simple aquí verdad si yo tengo
mi carbono unido con el oxígeno no
podemos pintar un enlace simple verdad
si hay si hay uno aquí pero también
puede haber dos entonces vamos a hacer
un híbrido de esto y es poner un enlace
doble parcial que lo vamos a representar
digamos con esto con esta línea punteada
verdad ahora también tenemos que este
carbono está unido a este otro carbono y
lo mismo tenemos para este enlace de
arriba verdad con este oxígeno que
tendríamos acá pues necesitamos poner un
enlace doble parcial también verdad
que quizás por cierto antes que nada me
faltó mencionar que aquí tenemos la
carga negativa en el oxígeno que se
encuentra arriba de nosotros verdad
entonces en realidad no podemos dibujar
un enlace sencillo en nuestro híbrido
tenemos que mostrar enlaces dobles
parciales verdad dibujadas con líneas
punteadas y también tenemos que poner
donde se localizan las cargas verdad que
justamente sería este en este caso o
esta carga que correspondería al otro
caso y de hecho como decimos es que la
carga está deslocalizada verdad no se
encuentra localizada en un oxígeno está
deslocalizada está distribuida de forma
pareja entre los dos oxígenos que
tenemos en esta molécula muy bien
entonces esta es una forma de
representar un híbrido y los estudios
nos han mostrado que el híbrido es una
forma más real de lo que es el año en
verdad así que estos estudios han hecho
que éstos
o más bien han trabajado con la longitud
de los enlaces y han visto que los
enlaces entre el carbono y el oxígeno
verdad en estos dos casos tienen de
hecho la misma longitud muy bien
entonces realmente estamos hablando de
la misma longitud del enlace y
nuevamente este híbrido es una mejor
digamos imagen de lo que el año
realmente es en la realidad
ahora pensemos qué es lo que ocurriría
si simplemente mover trasladamos estos
electrones a este enlace doble verdad
que podría ser algo que hubiera ocurrido
entonces qué es lo que obtendríamos
tendríamos aquí nuestro oxígeno
tendríamos aquí nuestro doble enlace
tendríamos este enlace este otro enlace
y aquí está nuestro oxígeno verdad y
ahorita voy a quitar el detalle de los
electrones pero si estos dos electrones
digamos que tenemos en el morado solo
formarán parte de este doble enlace
verdad podría ser una posibilidad además
de que por supuesto quedarán todos los
demás enlaces entonces en principio
podría ser posible pero tenemos un
detalle en este caso este carbono este
carbono central tendría cinco enlaces
alrededor de él
eso significa que tendría 10 electrones
verdad y eso no cumple con la regla del
octeto verdad sabemos que el carbono no
puede exceder d
el octeto de electrones porque es esto
es por su posición en la tabla periódica
así que no es una estructura válida y
por lo tanto este es uno de los patrones
que vamos a estar hablando quizás en el
próximo vídeo verdad este patrón es en
particular cuando tenemos una pareja de
electrones solitarios verdad
digamos cerca de un enlace pi ok que es
el ejemplo que tenemos en el año acetato
así que estas dos son dos estructuras
resonantes y quizás el problema con la
palabra resonante es que cuando eres un
estudiante podrías pensar que la unión
va a estar resonando de ida y de regreso
verdad entre este entre esta estructura
y esta otra verdad
sin embargo esto no es lo que implica el
nombre no no es de hecho lo que está
ocurriendo esto es simplemente que no
podré no podemos dibujar solo una de
estas dos estructuras verdad dos
estructuras de punto no es una
descripción adecuada porque los en
realidad lo que pasa es que los
electrones están deslocalizados así que
no es que
y resonando entre este estado y este
otro
así que cuando dibujes estructuras
resonantes digamos al menos en tu cabeza
tienes que pensar lo que significa la
idea de híbrido verdad que es que estas
estructuras resonantes van a
o más bien que representan que los
electrones están deslocalizados muy bien
ahora vamos a fijarnos en una aplicación
del unión acetato que íbamos a vamos a
bajar y
acá tenemos representado nuevamente
nuestra unión acetato y de hecho
hablamos hace ratito de ley de esta
cuestión de que estos dos estos dos
electrones pueden pasar a formar parte
de un enlace doble con este carbono
mientras que estos dos el perdón estos
no es sino este enlace que tenemos aquí
puede pasar a ser una pareja de
electrones solitarios alrededor de este
oxígeno así que en realidad esta carga
negativa no está localizado en este
oxígeno sino que también puede estar es
localizado entre estos dos
y de hecho esta cuestión de que la carga
negativa esté deslocalizada incrementa
la estabilidad del cañón de aquí ok
entonces este es relativo relativamente
más estable es este hecho aumenta la
estabilidad de nuestro año aumenta la
estabilidad de nuestro avión y esto es
lo que podríamos llamar como empuje de
electrones estamos moviendo el
electrones alrededor y es muy importante
sentirse cómodos con estos electrones
que se están moviendo y ser capaces de
seguirlos la única forma de volverse
buenos haciendo esto es con muchos
problemas de práctica así que por favor
continúen haciendo ejercicios de
práctica que vienen en sus libros de
texto
ahora si comparamos este caso con el
avión tóxico que tenemos del lado
derecho
si nosotros tratamos de hacer
exactamente lo mismo digamos con estos
dos electrones que tenemos por aquí
déjenme hacerlo quizás con otro con otro
color
si nosotros queremos hacer exactamente
lo mismo con estos dos electrones
digamos que estos dos pasarán a ser
parte o pasarán a formar un enlace doble
con este carbono en realidad tenemos que
observar que esto no es posible porque
este carbono aunque no está dibujado
explícitamente pero ya tiene sus cuatro
enlaces de verdad este carbono de aquí
está unido a dos hidrógenos verdad así
que si nosotros hiciéramos otro enlace
entre el carbono y el oxígeno tendríamos
cinco enlaces que están saliendo del
carbono y eso no está bien porque se
rompe la regla del octeto verdad
entonces está esto no va a ser posible
hacerlo con este unión es óxido y por lo
tanto no podemos dibujar una estructura
resonante así que los electrones
realmente están localizados en este
oxígeno tiene una carga formal negativa
completa y ya que no podemos digamos
distribuir la carga negativa o este este
avión
más inestable verdad entonces el hecho
de que la carga no esté deslocalizada va
a disminuir la estabilidad de este año
muy bien
ahora si nosotros pensamos en los ácidos
conjugados a estas dos bases verdad
entonces el ácido conjugado para esta
molécula por supuesto sería el ácido
acético verdad que sería justamente esta
molécula de aquí eso lo que unido a uno
por otro lado el ácido conjugado al ani
un tóxico sería por supuesto el etanol
verdad y el etanol simplemente lo voy a
hacer igual con rojo simplemente se
representa de esta forma y si nos
preguntamos cuál de ellos es más ácido
sabemos que el ácido acético es más ha
sido verdad y eso es porque tiene mayor
capacidad de donar un protón porque la
base conjugada es más estable verdad o
podríamos pensar que su podremos pensar
en su resonancia o la deslocalización de
sus electrones ahora si nosotros nos
fijamos en el etanol ok el etanol no es
tan dado a donar su protón verdad
simplemente porque la base conjugada del
año net óxido no es tan estable porque
no podemos dibujar estructuras
resonantes para ella verdad así que la
carga negativa no va a ser posible el
ser deslocalizada simplemente está
localizada en este oxígeno y esto es
simplemente una de las aplicaciones
pensando en esto
duras resonantes verdad y nuevamente
tenemos que hacer muchos ejercicios de
práctica ahora bien en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a hablar de distintos
patrones que podríamos buscar para y que
de hecho ya hemos hablado en en este
vídeo verdad tomamos un par de
electrones solitarios que estaban junto
a un enlace y verdad y de hecho así
pudimos dibujar estructuras resonantes
para él ahora no tenemos esa situación
con el led óxido tenemos un par de
electrones pero que no están cercanos a
un enlace pitt así que vamos a ver este
y otros ejemplos más en el próximo vídeo